bonjour à tous je vous propose d'écouter
cet après-midi le vote du projet de loi
de lutte contre le terrorisme
le texte a été adopté à la quasi
unanimité par l'assemblée nationale la
semaine dernière je vous rappelle que ce
projet de loi prévoit notamment une
interdiction administrative de sortie du
territoire est un délit d'entreprise
terroristes individuels l'objectif est
donc de limiter la menace terroriste en
france est d'entraver les départs des
jeunes candidats au jihad
on sait que mille français ont été ou
sont impliqués dans des filières vers la
syrie et l'irak parmi ces mille
personnes plus de 350 combattent
actuellement dans ces pays alors la
mesure phare du projet de loi
l'interdiction de sortie du territoire
cherche donc à empêcher ces départs de
ces jeunes français candidats au djihad
voilà je vous propose donc de rejoindre
tout de suite l'hémicycle pour écouter
la discussion générale sur ce texte
alors l'ordre du jour appelle l'examen
des conclusions de la commission mixte
paritaire chargée d'élaborer un texte
sur les dispositions restant en
discussion du projet de loi renforçant
les dispositions relatives à la lutte
contre le terrorisme
dans la discussion générale
la parole est à monsieur alain richard
co rapporteur pour le sénat de la
commission mixte paritaire
madame la présidente madame la ministre
chers collègues
le projet de loi qui vous est soumis a
été à trouver dans une version de
compromis unanimement par la commission
mixte paritaire
c'est dire que ce débat s'ouvre dans un
contexte de
d'assentiment sur ce texte que je
qualifierais de résidence républicaine
je résume très sommairement les points
principaux du point de vue de la police
administrative du point de vue des
mesures de prévention puisque c'est
ainsi que nous nous sommes partagé le
travail avec mon co rapporteurs donc la
commission mixte paritaire a confirmé
l'instauration de la procédure
d'interdiction de sortie du territoire
qui est complété par une interdiction de
transport imposé aux transporteurs et
qui a été complétée devant nous mais
également approuvé par la commission
mixte paritaire par une direction
administrative du territoire qui vise
également à éloigner ou à maintenir
éloigné des personnes contre lesquelles
on dispose d'éléments indiquant leur
participation des activités terroristes
je rappelle que les deux assemblées se
sont mises d'accord sur le fait que ces
mesures comme toute mesure de police
même de grande gravité
se faisait l'objet de recours qui ont
été fermement et précisément encadrée
devant le juge administratif dont
l'office et de statuer sur ces questions
en matière de police administrative et
de mesures de prévention je rappelle que
nous avons aussi modifié la procédure de
saisie d'avoirs
de saisie d'avoirs financiers lorsqu'ils
sont
lorsque c'est cette saisie est prononcé
pour des motifs de lutte antiterroriste
le ministre d'intérieur il sera à
l'avenir associés
nous avons adopté d'un commun accord
l'article 9 qui porte sur la procédure
administrative de suppression des
contenus terroriste sur internet 7 est
un des sujets c'est bien le puits plus
difficiles et les plus discutés la
commission de l'assemblée nationale
avait fait de notre point de vue une
avancée importante
puisque tout en conservant une procédure
administrative ce qui était le souhaite
tout le monde pour des raisons de
célérité et d'efficacité
elle avait introduit une participation
d'un représentant de la commission
nationale informatique et libertés dans
l'appréciation des motifs de de cette
suppression de contenu nous avons
dialogué et nous avons convenu
finalement qu'il valait mieux que ce
soit un membre de la commission
nationale de la cnil qui assure cette
mission auprès de l'administration et
nous nous sommes entendus aussi pour ce
qu'il y avait un problème de d'entrée en
vigueur de la disposition que le membre
de la cnil qui seraient affectés à cette
mission l'exercera pour la durée de son
mandat au sein de la clinique c'est ce
qui nous a conduits à le trouver
d'accord sur cette disposition
nous avions des dix versions différentes
en ce qui concerne l'article 15 relatif
à la durée de conservation des
enregistrements
issue l'interception de sécurité
le gouvernement
constatant ce désaccord entre les deux
assemblées la difficulté qu'ils voyaient
à appliquer l'une ou l'autre version
nous a recommandés et nous l'avons suivi
d'un commun accord de ne pas maintenir
cet article donc le dispositif actuel
issu de la loi de 91 sur la durée de
conservation
de ces de ces enregistrements demeure en
vigueur et puis là aussi sur la
proposition du gouvernement je crois que
les deux assemblées ont été 2 le bon
vouloir
par rapport aux préoccupations de mise à
jour juridique que nous apportait le
gouvernement nous sommes trouvé d'accord
pour ratifier explicitement le code de
sécurité intérieure qui étaient en
attente de cette ratification ce qui a
imposé un travail assez long que je
qualifierais familièrement de peignage
des conséquences de cette ratification
qui a donné bien du travail à nos
collaborateurs dans les deux assemblées
et nous avons également conclu sur une
rédaction commune de ceux de cet
ensemble de dispositions gratification
et la sortie de modification je dois
dire que le climat dans lequel nous
avons travaillé dans la commission mixte
paritaire a été extrêmement constructive
de la part de l'ensemble des deux
délégations nous avions tous conscience
de la responsabilité devant laquelle
nous plaçait ce texte et les raisons
pour lesquelles il est déposé
les collègues de l'assemblée nationale
ont accepté que les rédactions finales
qui allient très largement compte du
texte issu du sénat ce qui se comprend
bien puisque nous avions connu un délai
pour travailler pour affiner le texte un
peu plus long que celui dont ils avaient
eux-mêmes discuter disposer veut dire et
donc c'est ce qui a conduit à ce que
nous trouvions finalement sans grande
difficulté après un travail plus
approfondi entre les rapporteurs comme
ces usages que nous trouvions une
rédaction commune sur l'ensemble du
projet de loi avec une toute petite une
petite faille que le gouvernement à
rectifier puisque dans la mise au point
du dossier nous avions commis une petite
erreur sur un renvoi le texte devrait
terminer cette brève est positive
présentation en soulignant l'esprit
d'écouté et de des changes authentique
comptable bénéficié je le dis devant
vous madame qui représentait le
gouvernement aujourd'hui nota dont a
fait montre bernard cazeneuve qui a été
un interlocuteur attentif
ceux soucieux de convaincre est capable
de
d'évoluer d'écouté comme comme nous le
connaissons tous mais je voulais
profiter de cet instant compte tenu de
la forte charge de responsabilités avec
laquelle à laquelle il fait face avec
beaucoup de force de caractère pour lui
témoigner notre habitude
merci chers collègues
la parole est à monsieur jean jacques
hyest co rapporteur pour le sénat de la
commission mixte paritaire
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues comme vous
l'indiquez mon imminent co-rapporteur la
collection vive paritaire à être parvenu
à un accord sur le projet de loi relatif
à la lutte contre le terrorisme
en définitive il restait peu de
désaccords entre noah sont nos deux
assemblées sur la partie du texte
relative à la répression pénale des
actes de terrorisme dont j'avais partie
plus particulièrement la charge
je rappelle que les deux assemblées
avaient déjà adoptée dans les mêmes
thèmes d'articles 3 qui inclut les
infractions relatives aux produits
explosifs dans la liste des infractions
pouvant recevoir la qualification
terroriste
dès lors qu'elles sont accomplies avec
cette intention
par ailleurs la commission mixte
paritaire a approuvé la création par
l'article 5 d'un nouveau délit
d'entreprise individuelle de préparation
d'un acte terroriste
en retenant la rédaction issue du sénat
à l'exception de la préparation
de la notion de préparation logistique
de l'acte terroriste qui semblait après
beaucoup du débat trop imprécises et
était finalement pas nécessaires pour
couvrir l'ensemble des cas de figure
rencontrées par les juges
antiterroristes
les enquêteurs et la justice ne
disposeront ainsi
désormais d'un fondement juridique
efficace pour appréhender le phénomène
d'auto radicalisation qui caractérise
plus en plus souvent les auteurs d'actes
terroristes tout en évitant grâce à
l'exigence d'une sorte de faisceau
d'indicés la paix ni la pénalisation de
la seule intention criminelle ce qui
n'aurait pas été compatible avec les
principes de notre droit pénal
en revanche concernant les délits d'
apologie et de provocation aux
terroristes qui figure à l'article 4 du
projet de loi la commission mixte
paritaire a préféré revenir pour
l'essentiel au texte initial du
gouvernement en faisant sortir de la loi
du 29 juillet 1881 sur la liberté de la
presse
l'ensemble des actes d' apologie et de
provocation
l'idée émise par notre commission des
lois et qui avait été suivi par le sénat
qui était de l'incriminer que les faits
commis sur internet en temps qu'il
comportait une dangerosité
supplémentaire du fait des spécificités
de ce média n'a donc pas été retenue par
la commission mixte paritaire
il faudra pourtant revenir sur ce sujet
tant des caractéristiques du web rend
nécessaire un traitement nouveau du
point de vue la procédure pénale
d'ailleurs la rédaction retenue et riche
tout de même la commission des faits par
le moyen d'internet en circonstance
aggravante du nouveau délit ce qui
montre d'une certaine manière le bien
fondé du raisonnement qui avait été
celui de notre commission
s'agissant des dispositions relatives à
la centralisation auprès de la
juridiction parisienne du traitement
judiciaire des actes terroristes dans
les articles 7 et 7 bis notamment ceux
commis en détention par des personnes
déjà condamnées pour ce type
d'infraction c'est la rédaction plus
claire et précise notre assemblée qui
étaient pour l'essentiel retenu ce
parachèvement de la centralisation
auprès du tribunal de grande instance de
la cour d'appel et des juges
d'instruction de paris et d'ailleurs un
aspect important de ce texte dans cette
compétence nationale
concurrente de la juridiction parisienne
est une pièce essentielle de notre
dispositif anti terroriste
enfin comme l'a rappelé alain richard
mais je ne peux pas résister au plaisir
de le redire concernant la durée de
conservation des enregistrements des
interceptions de sécurité
la commission mixte paritaire à défaut
de trouver une rédaction pleinement
satisfaisante pour concilier
l'efficacité du contrôle de la cncis
commission nationale de contrôle des
interceptions de sécurité pour ceux qui
ne la connaîtraient pas avec la demande
du ministre de l'intérieur madame la
ministre récurrentes puisque ça fait au
moins quatre ou cinq fois que le
ministère de l'intérieur et c'est de
nous augmenter ces délais on a décidé de
la suppression pure et simple de
l'article 15 ça ne peut que réjouir bien
entendu ceux qui avaient milité pour la
suppression de cet article
voici mes chers collègues des
dispositions du projet de loi tel kiss
et des travaux de la commission mixte
paritaire comme on l'a dit complété par
un amendement que le coordination déposé
par le gouvernement
je pense que ce texte
compte tenu de l'évolution du terrorisme
est extrêmement utile doit donner à la
fois à nos forces à la fois nos services
de renseignement à nos forces de
sécurité et à la justice des moyens de
combattre c'est ces nouvelles formes de
terrorisme
connaissent point entendu ou lu dans
certaines gazettes sur le respect des
libertés publiques
je rappelle que tout ce texte nous
paraît être parfaitement conforme à
l'état de droit et que ce ne sont pas
les procédures administratives qui sont
interdites mais de la condition qu'elle
soit contrôlée par le juge qu'ils soient
administratifs ou judiciaires je crois
qu'on feront en il y avait confusion
dans l'esprit de certains mais ça ne
nous étonnera pas complètement en tous
les cas je me réjouis de l'aboutissement
consensuelle et le fait qu'on ait eu
deux co-rapporteurs a permis d'avancer
peut-être plus vite à au moment où le
sénat
était en renouvellement pour permettre
de travailler ensemble et je me réjouis
d'ailleurs de le travail que nous avons
pu réaliser avec alain richard je vous
remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
madame myriam 1 comme rick secrétaire
d'état chargée de la politique de la
ville
madame la présidente
messieurs les rapporteurs mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs pour commencer
je vous prie de bien vouloir excuser
l'absence du ministre intérieur bernard
cazeneuve
nous assistons avec la guerre civile en
syrie puis en irak à une mutation rapide
du terrorisme encore récemment le
terrorisme était réservée à une poignée
d'individus faisant le choix de la
clandestinité au sein de groupes
structurés difficile d'accès il est
désormais en libre accès tout à chacun
peut désormais sans quitter son domicile
consulter des sites faisant l'apologie
du meurtre en masse du martyre de
l'attentât suicide ce auto-radicalisés
puis se décider pour un aller simple
vers les terres du jihad le cas échéant
en famille
tout à chacun peut avec une facilité
déconcertante
acquérir un savoir-faire minimale pour
commettre un attentat terroriste de
proximité la mutation qui s'opère
consiste pour ces organisations
criminelles à tirer parti des nouvelles
technologies de l'information pour
inoculer massenet massivement le virus
du terrorisme dans les esprits et pour
tromper certains de nos concitoyens
le plus souvent les plus jeunes les plus
faibles en laissant croire qu'ils sont
devenus les ennemis de leur propre pays
le nombre des jeunes français
radicaliser combattants sur le
territoire d'opérations syrien n'a cessé
de croître
une réponse ferme et adapté donc
nécessaire pour éviter à de jeunes
français de succomber à la tentation du
martyr et à la fascination du meurtre
notre devoir collectif et de tout faire
pour contenir la menace potentielle que
représentent le retour en france de
combattants formés en syrie au maniement
des armes à des explosifs ayant sous
souvent commis les pires atrocités
criminels
endoctrinés par des discours de haine
envers l'occident est souvent
déshumanisé par l'expérience quotidienne
de la violence
certains nous le constatons déjà or ont
fui de leur propre initiative la syrie
et chercheront sans doute à oublier
cette terrible épreuve
mais nous ne pouvons courir le risque
dans les faits d'autres tenter de
reproduire sur le sol français au nom du
djihad la violence barbare qu'ils auront
connu en syrie ou en irak
comme vous le savez face à de telles
menaces et afin de garantir la sécurité
de nos concitoyens
le gouvernement a réagi sans tarder avec
fermeté et vigilance
depuis avril le gouvernement a créé le
centre national d'assistance et de
prévention de la radicalisation en
charge de la prise en compte et de
l'orientation des signalements des
candidats au départ auquel une prise en
charge est proposé
ces signalements lui parviennent soit
directement par la plateforme
téléphonique et internet dédié soit par
le réseau d état major de sécurité animé
localement par les préfets les
procureurs de la république
entre fin avril et fin octobre ce sont
près de 600 personnes qui ont fait
l'objet d'un signalement dont 25 % de
mineurs
s'agissant en particulier des mineurs la
garde des sceaux et le ministre de
l'intérieur ont dès le 5 mai 2014 donné
des instructions au préfet au procureur
afin d'organiser leur suivi dès lors
détection incluant notamment une mesure
d' opposition à la sortie du territoire
parallèlement à ces mesures un
département de lutte contre la
radicalisation a été créé au sein de
l'uclat unité de coordination de lutte
antiterroriste afin d'améliorer la
transmission à l'exploitation du
renseignement entre les administrations
concernées le bureau du renseignement de
la direction de l'administration
pénitentiaire par exemple est désormais
représentée au sein de l'ue clac dans la
continuité du plan adopté dès avril
dernier le gouvernement a jugé
indispensable de renforcer notre
législation pour entraver l'action et la
propagande des filières jihadistes et
contrarier les projets de ceux qui sont
tentés de les rejoindre
un débat riche et digne en séance le 15
juillet dernier à l'assemblée nationale
le 15 octobre dernier au sénat nous a
rassemblés nous permettant d'aboutir aux
textes efficaces qui vous est
aujourd'hui soumis je tiens donc au nom
du ministre de l'intérieur a remercié
vivement les rapporteurs du texte jean
jacques hyest et alain richard
comme l'ensemble des parlementaires qui
ont contribuer à l'améliorer
quand il s'agit de la protection de la
france et des français
le consensus républicain est une
nécessité
le projet de loi renforçant les
dispositions relatives à la lutte contre
le terrorisme transcende les clivages
partisans ce dont nous nous réjouissons
tous ce consensus lui donne davantage de
forces
l'objectif du gouvernement était de
retenir la version la plus ambitieuse
possible du texte incluant plusieurs
mesures votées à l'assemblée nationale
et un certain nombre de dispositions
intégré au sénat c'est ce à quoi nous
sommes parvenus après adoption du texte
par la commission mixte paritaire qui
permet de garantir dans le respect de
nos échanges au parlement l'effectivité
des mesures de la sécurité juridique des
dispositifs
je rappelle que la loi repose sur quatre
innovations majeures qui tout respecte
l'état de droit et demeure soumise à un
contrôle étroit du juge la première
c'est innovation c'est l'interdiction de
sortie du territoire prévu à l'article
1er de la loi qui permettra tout d'abord
aux autorités de s'opposer au départ de
nos ressortissants hors de france
dès lors qu'il existe des raisons
sérieuses de croire que leur déplacement
à une finalité terroriste ou que leur
retour porterait atteinte à la sécurité
publique
rigoureusement encadré dans ses motifs
et dans sa durée dont le maximum est
fixé à deux ans pouvant faire l'objet
d'un recours devant le juge
administratif qui pourrait agir en
référé cette mesure sera rendue
pleinement effective sans même attendre
la mise en oeuvre du pnr passenger name
record grâce au retrait de la carte
nationale d'identité et à la validation
immédiat des documents d'identité contre
récépissé
des précautions supplémentaires ont été
prises pour éviter que ce dernier ne
présente un caractère stigmatisant pour
l'individu concerné je veux remercier
cette question la contribution précieuse
du parlement par ailleurs pour compléter
ce dispositif nouveau l'interdiction
d'entrée et de séjour sur le territoire
national pour les étrangers ne résidant
pas en france l'article 1 bis a été
adoptée à la suite des changes danse à
l'assemblée nationale et sur la base un
amendement du gouvernement au sénat
deuxième innovation
la création prévue à l'article 5 du
délit d'entreprises individuelles
terroriste permettra d'adapter notre
législation aux spécificités du
terrorisme contemporain sans pour autant
mettre en cause le principe de légalité
des délits et des peines
se délient nouveau est en effet
nécessaire pour pouvoir appréhender
avant le passage à l'acte un individu
isolé résolu à commettre un acte
terroriste
dès lors que celui-ci est détectée en
revanche l'élément matériel relatif à
l'acquisition de moyens logistiques de
la définition de l'entreprise
individuelle terroriste a été supprimée
tandis que la possibilité pour les
enquêteurs et magistrats de saisir
directement le centre technique
d'assistance à des fins de décryptage a
été finalement maintenu
troisième innovation
pour entraver la diffusion de messages
de haine et de propagande terroriste sur
internet
l'article 9 rendra possible blocage
administratif des sites compétents ainsi
les dispositions de la loi du 21 juin
2004 pour la confiance dans l'économie
numérique
l'autorité administrative pourra
désormais demander aux éditeurs et
hébergeurs de sites lorsqu'ils sont
identifiés de procéder au retrait des
contenus qu'ils appellent au terrorisme
ou en font l'apologie
ou bien à défaut aux fournisseurs
d'accès de bloquer l'accès aux sites à
l'instar de ce que le législateur a déjà
prévu pour les sites et de pauvres
pédopornographiques excusez moi en vertu
du principe de subsidiarité introduit
par les députés ce blocage ciblées et
limitées au strict nécessaire
s'effectuera comme larry charles a
indiqué sous le contrôle d'une
personnalité qualifiée désignée par la
cnil et sera soumis à la juridiction
administrative
la personnalité qualifiée aura en effet
une faculté de contester le blocage a
posteriori devant le juge administratif
par ailleurs la possibilité pour
l'administration voté par le sénat de
demander aux moteurs de recherche de
deals référencement des sites illicites
complète sera utilement la palette
d'outils de lutte contre la polo j des
crimes terroristes sur internet le
dispositif n'en sera que plus efficace
sur cette question le gouvernement a
tout mis en oeuvre pour parer le risque
de surblocage et garantir un maximum
d'effectivité de la mesure ce dispositif
a été largement revue dès l'examen du
projet de loi en commission des lois à
l'assemblée nationale ce qui a permis le
développement d'un débat fécond sur
cette question enfin comme l'a indiqué
jean jacques hyest l'apologie et la
provocation aux théories de ne relever
lé rond ne relèveront plus du délit
d'opinion et donc de la loi de 1881 sur
la liberté de la presse mais du droit
commun certaines des techniques
spéciales denquête applicables au
terrorisme leur seront également
applicables sous le contrôle de
l'autorité judiciaire
le champ des incriminations d'apologie
et de provocation au terrorisme n'est en
revanche pas modifiée ou de ces
innovations majeures d'autres éléments
doivent être soulignés la première c'est
la possibilité donnée à l' agence de
gestion de recouvrement des avoirs
criminels de concourir au financement de
la lutte contre la criminalité c'est
l'article 15 ter qui permettra dans
l'immédiat de financer le dispositif des
repentis et à terme d'intéresser les
forces de sécurité aux saisies opérées
c'est un dispositif auquel beaucoup
d'entre vous étaient attachés de longue
date il figure maintenant dans le texte
en second lieu les mesures
exceptionnelles de sûreté aéroportuaire
pourront être adoptés le cas échéant ce
dispostif poussé par le secrétariat
général de la défense nationale
permettra de mettre en place un
dispositif vigipirate en milieu aérien
de plus les ordonnances relatives à la
partie législative du code de la
sécurité intérieure ont été ratifiés un
code de déontologie commun à la police
et à la gendarmerie nationale a été créé
les dispositions également permettant
aux services d'avoir accès aux fichiers
dans le cadre de la lutte antiterroriste
et de réaliser des contrôles dans les
trains trans nationaux prorogé sans
discontinuité depuis 2006 et une ultime
fois dans le cadre de l'article 1er de
la loi antiterroriste de septembre 2012
ont été également pérenniser par voie
d'amendement gouvernemental au sénat en
revanche comme l'ont indiqué les
rapporteurs l'article 15 allongeant la
durée de conservation des
enregistrements des interceptions de
sécurité a finalement été supprimé
je le répète cette loi est aujourd'hui
nécessaire à la sécurité de notre pays
certes il n'existe pas de risque de
risque zéro en matière de lutte contre
le terrorisme
mais ce n'est pas une raison pour rester
inactif grâce aux dispositifs nouveaux
créés par la loi l'entreprise criminels
des terroristes ou de ceux qui veulent
les rejoindre or a été entravée des
internautes souvent jeunes auront
échappé à leur action de propagande
la justice est sous son contrôle les
services de police auront à leur
disposition des moyens d'action et
d'investigation plus efficace et plus
protecteurs de nos concitoyens j'ajoute
que les dispositions que l'on retrouve
dans cette version issue de la
commission mixte s'inspire très
largement des travaux accomplis par la
haute assemblée
je crois que la calm résolution qui
habitent ce texte fruit d'un consensus
dont nous pouvons être fiers et à la
fois sa grande force et même l'honneur
de notre république je vous remercie
merci madame la ministre
dans la suite de la discussion générale
la parole et monsieur michel mercier
pour le groupe u10 us et la parole
monsieur président
je me
sa présidente madame la ministre
messieurs les co-rapporteurs chaque
aulagnon la commission mixte paritaire
s'est donc mise d'accord sur cette loi
visant à mieux armer l'état dans la
lutte contre le terrorisme et il est
heureux que cet accord ait pu se
réaliser que tous les républicains se
rassemblent 1 pour lutter contre le
terrorisme est quelque chose qui est
assez remarquable et qui marque aussi
une évolution des esprits il suffit de
se souvenir de ce qui s'est passé en
marche 2012 par exemple après la ferme
ra et ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
et moi je veux saluer cette évolution
des esprits pas regretter ce qui s'est
passé à 2012 mais
être satisfaits de la prise de
conscience du vrai risque que de
terrorisme fait courir à deux
institutions à la république et à la
liberté et c'est très bien et très
heureux et que la commission mixte
paritaire et pu parvenir à cet accord
sur un texte qui va mieux armé l'état
pour lutter contre le terroriste même si
nous savons bien que l'imagination des
terroristes passé arrêté et qu'il y aura
probablement un jour un autre texte pour
tenir compte de ces évolutions et ne pas
être prêt
devancée et des évolutions qui le plus
souvent sont technologique bien se
serait refusé et de mieux cerner ce
texte ne satisfait il satisfait parce
que par les mesures qu'ils courent porte
qui reali je crois un bon équilibre
entre ne respect qui est dû à tout
citoyen qui exercent qui vit normalement
et qui a besoin pour cela de l'usaj de
liberté publique fondamentale et puis il
a nécessité de le protéger parce que
l'idée de mettre en balance les libertés
publiques et le terrorisme me semble une
idée un peu bizarre pour pas dire plus
c'est le terrorisme qui est la négation
de la liberté et on peut pas mettre sur
le même plan libertés publiques et
terrorisme on doit combattre le
terrorisme pour assurer la liberté
publique et c'est cela que je souhaitais
pouvoir dire très clairement devant
notre haute assemblée alors les mesures
que contient le texte sont des mesures
qui corresponde à la situation dans
laquelle je me trouve dont a besoin
la république pour faire face que ce
soit les forces
le police ou de gendarmerie pour
prévenir le terrorisme que ce soit les
magistrats pour pouvoir
poursuivre et condamner et les actes de
terrorisme je veux simplement noté
quelques unes de ces mesures est
attendue
est celle prévue à l'article 1er qui va
permettre à l'état d'interdire le départ
de france dans ressortissants français
et lorsqu'il existe des raisons
sérieuses de penser qu'ils se projettent
des déplacements à l'étranger pour
participer à des activités
terroristes
surtout souligner les nouvelles
incriminations plus dissuasive et la
procédure et qui a été retenu par la
commission mixte paritaire pour assurer
la poursuite de ceux qui réalisent ray
de telles fêtes alors deux choses me
semblent importantes tout d'abord le
fait de reconnaître des lidd entreprises
terroristes individuels cela manquait
d'hommes peu panel en quelque sorte
pénale on avait bien
combattre le terrorisme
dès lors que c'était un terrorisme qui
étaient perpétrées par des groupes mais
pas par des terroristes individuels pour
qu'on sait bien aujourd'hui et les
phénomènes de radicalisation sont
souvent des phénomènes individuelles
notamment dans les prisons où là où
commence parfois là où souvent la
radicalisation et puis je veux souligner
l'effort qui est fait la majorité
sénatoriale
d'accepter que désormais je te demande
d'être plus longtemps je l'avais demandé
dans d'autres circonstances et je n'ai
pas changé de position d'avoir accepté
et que l'on sorte de la loi du 29
juillet 1881 la procédure pour
poursuivre l et délits de terrorisme
el adoua 280 défilés assurer la liberté
de la presse elle n'est pas destinée à
permettre de lutter contre le terrorisme
il fait qu'on ait pu tous ensemble
assemblée nationale-sénat
majorité-opposition
accepté
d'avoir une procédure claire la
procédure antiterroriste qui sera
utilisé dans tous les cas de poursuites
contre le terrorisme est un progrès
important pour l'efficacité de la lutte
contre le terrorisme alors oui cette loi
va nous permettre d'assurer les libertés
publiques parce qu'on pourra combattre
plus efficacement le terrorisme et c'est
la raison pour laquelle notre groupe
votera à l'unanimité ce texte merci
merci chers collègues
la parole est à madame esther benbassa
pour le groupe écologiste
monsieur le président madame la
secrétaire d'état monsieur le président
de la commission des lois messieurs les
rapporteurs mes chers collègues
la lutte contre le terrorisme est une
nécessité impérieuse et chacun aura eu
l'occasion de le signaler les progrès
irrésistible de l'implantation de l'état
islamique sur le terrain dans une région
à feu et à sang depuis des années ainsi
que l'insupportable assassinat de notre
compatriote hervé gourdet l'algérie et
les différentes des décapitations
d'occidentaux sont venus nous rappeler
notre vulnérabilité face à cette
barbarie le groupe écologiste que je
représente aujourd'hui à pleine
conscience du devoir qui est le nom de
mener un combat résolu contre toutes les
formes de terrorisme et de violence
toutefois j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire
lors de la première lecture nous sommes
également convaincus que la volonté de
rendre plus efficace notre légitime
lutte contre le terrorisme ne justifie
assurément pas qu'on brade les libertés
individuelles
je veux également réaffirmé russie comme
je lé fais il ya deux ans comme je lé
fais il ya quelques semaines qu'il est
surtout urgent de s'attaquer aux causes
profondes de l'émergence d'un terrorisme
désormais endogène
peut-être faut-il légiférer mais les
surtout urgent de travailler en amont de
tout faire pour tenter de comprendre
pourquoi ces jeunes y compris l'ombre de
récents convertis à l'islam se découvre
soudain une vocation de djihadistes nous
pouvons adopter toutes les lois toutes
les mesures dissuasives ou répressive
j'en suis convaincu
nous ne pourrons endiguer un phénomène
que nous ne comprenons pas comme en
première lecture la question qui se pose
à nous est celle de savoir si le texte
issu de la commission mixte paritaire
atteint le juste équilibre entre
efficacité de la lutte contre le
terrorisme est protection des libertés
individuelles qui sont au fondement de
notre démocratie
considérant que le projet de loi initial
n'était pas satisfaisant du point de vue
de la protection des libertés
individuelles
le groupe écologiste y étaient opposés
nous constatons à regret que le texte de
la commission mixte paritaire ne l'est
pas davantage
je ne reviendra pas je ne reviendrai pas
sur l'ensemble des mesures prévues mais
mesure qui pose de nombreux problèmes et
qui constituent des atteintes à la
liberté d'aller et venir à la liberté de
circulation dans l'espace schengen ont
pris à partie au principe du
contradictoire en principe de l'absence
de répression des actes préparatoires au
principe de proportionnalité
la liste bien sûr est longue par
ailleurs si les lois antiterroristes
sont nécessaires madame la secrétaire
d'état elles ne doivent pas poursuivre
d'autres objectifs justement que la
lutte contre le terrorisme et ne doivent
pas pouvoir être assumant talise et à
d'autres fins que penser à cet égard de
l'arctique 1er bis introduit au sénat
par la voie d'un amendement du
gouvernement et qui ne crée rien de
moins qu'une interdiction administrative
du territoire français il s'agit ici il
s'agit ici de pouvoir interdire l'entrée
en france d'un ressortissant de l'union
européenne n'en déplaise aux principes
de liberté de circulation
silva présente je vous cite une menace
pour la sécurité publique
la menace si elle doit être je cite
réelle actuelle est suffisamment grave
pour un intérêt fondamental de la
société
fin de la citation ne doit pas forcément
être en lien avec une entreprise
terroriste
le mot n'étant même pas utilisés vous
comprendrez madame la secrétaire d'état
notre inquiétude partagée par de
nombreuses associations et défenseur des
droits et rang des étrangers quant à
l'utilisation qui pourrait être faite de
cette mesure la définition est beaucoup
trop large et permet en real en réalité
d'interdire l'accès au territoire à peu
près à tout le monde certains ont pu y
voir un amendement anti roms et je ne
suis pas loin de partager cette vision
peut-être cette mesure ne sera t'elle
pas appliqué à cette fin sous votre
administration madame la secrétaire
d'état mais elle continuera d'exister
après et de pouvoir être utilisés à des
fins de gestion des flux migratoires au
sein de l'union européenne
dois-je vous rappeler chers collègues
que le conseil d'état a considéré le 1er
octobre dernier que la mendicité
agressive d'une famille rom constituer
une menace touchant aux intérêts
fondamentaux de la société
en l'espèce la femme concerné n'avait
été ni condamné ni même poursuivis
pénalement
cette mesure à elle seule est l'amant et
la manière dont elle a été introduite
symbolise l'esprit d'un texte dont les
dispositions sont au mieux inefficaces
au pire susceptible de porter atteinte
aux libertés et droits fondamentaux que
nous avons pour mission de protéger en
toute cohérence le groupe écologiste
n'apportera pas son soutien au présent
projet de loi je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
la présidente eliane assassi pour le
groupe crc
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues
je crois que je vais avoir moi aussi une
voix dissonante sur ce texte et sur les
conclusions de la commission mixte
paritaire mais je pense que ça ne
surprendra personne vous savez cela fait
déjà plusieurs mois que des juristes des
associations de défense des droits de
l'homme des associations de simples
citoyens tous républicains
dénoncent ce projet de loi qui renforce
les dispositions relatives à la lutte
contre le terrorisme car elle considère
et nous le considérons aussi qu'il
contient des mesures attentatoires aux
libertés individuelles et souvent
dérogatoire au droit commun
interdictions administratives de sortie
de territoire création du délit
d'entreprises individuelles terroriste
blocages administratifs des sites
internet modifications comme
substantielle de la procédure pénale au
delà des actes de terrorisme alors le
texte qui est issu de la commission
mixte paritaire non seulement confirme
ces mesures mais ils ont validé autres
introduite par le gouvernement par voie
d'amendement ici au sénat et bien
évidemment je pense à l'article 1er bis
qui introduit un dispositif
d'interdiction administrative du
territoire dans le code de l'entrée et
du séjour des étrangers et du droit
d'asile je ne paie pas répéter ce qui
est inscrit de grenade on dans le texte
benbassa vient de le faire mais vous
conviendrez quand même que les motifs
qui sont invoqués ne sont nullement
limité au terrorisme cette mesure est
extrêmement l'âge et elle permet
d'interdire l'accès au territoire à peu
près à n'importe qui par exemple aux
manifestants ressortissant d'un état
membre de l'union européenne
d'autant que vous l'amour et la
situation économique européenne à
qu'elle peut provoquer des mouvements
sociaux contestataires mais également
humain benbassa raison il veut là je la
suis aux populations roms largement
stigmatiser qui sont près de 6 millions
à vivre sur le territoire de l'union
européenne et à ce sujet monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur s'est indigné
d'un procès d'intention que nous
l'aurions fait en précisant qu'il
appliquait la fameuse résolution des
nations unies du 25 septembre qui vise à
empêcher la circulation des groupes
terroristes afin d'entraver les
déplacements de ceux qui préparent des
actes d re terroriste sur le sol
français qui met en eux en danger les
intérêts fondamentaux de la nation comme
le précise le texte
nous nous ne pensons pas se cacher
derrière la résolution des nations unies
est bien commode lorsque l'on sait à la
lecture du texte que ces mesures peuvent
toucher n'importe quel citoyen temps les
éléments d'incrimination sont fous en
effet à cet ajout à l'article 1er bis du
texte d'une part ne précise rien et
d'autre part et d'une grande gravité il
s'agit en effet d'une très sérieuse
entorse à la libre circulation des
personnes garanti par l'article 27 de la
directive 2004 38 ce du parlement
européen et du conseil du 29 avril 2004
relative aux droits des citoyens de
l'union et des membres de leurs familles
de circuler et de séjourner librement
sur le territoire des états membres une
entorse à cette liberté qui n'est pas
proportionnée en effet elle est
justifiée par une menace qui n'est pas
suffisamment étayée elle est subjective
est laissée à la seule appréciation du
ministre de l'intérieur par l'octroi
d'un pouvoir discrétionnaire face à une
sanction absolue une interdiction du
territoire et une intervention trop
tardive du juge juge administratif de
surcroît nous ne sommes pas loin de
l'arbitraire sont couverts de motifs
généraux et légitimes tels que la lutte
contre le terrorisme
il est octroyé donc de manière excessive
et sans garantie la possibilité au
ministre de l'intérieur et j'attire
votre attention au ministre de
l'intérieur d' aujourd'hui comme celui
de demain
d'interdire l'entrée sur le territoire
un ressortissant européen
jamais madame la secrétaire d'état
jamais je n'aurais imaginé un
gouvernement comme le vôtre et recours à
de telles méthodes je n'ose imaginer la
réaction de mes collègues sur les bancs
de gauche de cette assemblée si la
droite on avait usé mais ça c'était hier
je pense également à l'article 9 qui
prévoit le plan gâche le peloton le
blocage administratif des sites internet
provoquant à la commission d'actes de
terrorisme en faisant l'apologie
l'amendement introduit à la dernière
minute ici par le gouvernement donne à
l'autorité administrative le pouvoir
d'exiger des moteurs de recherche qu'il
défère déférence des sites sans
intervention du juge ainsi si l'autorité
administrative estime qu'un site fait
l'apologie du terrorisme notion définie
de manière vague il pourra ordonner à
tous les moteurs de recherche de ne plus
l'affiché sur leur page de résultats de
recherche
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur a
précisé je cite que cette possibilité de
déférencement était déjà prévue par la
loi concernant les jeux en ligne
mais ce qu'il a oublié de dire monsieur
le ministre de l'intérieur surtout de
préciser c'est que pour déférence et un
site de paris en ligne illégal
l'autorité de régulation des jeux en
ligne doit
impérativement passer par un juge qui
intervient en référé or dans le projet
de loi qui nous occupe aujourd'hui
l'intervention du juge n'ait pas prévu
puisqu'il donne le pouvoir de censure à
l'administration qui contacter
directement le moteur de recherche une
manipulation politique exemplaire pour
une mesure rajouter à la baule alors
vous l'auront vous l'aurez compris nous
nous opposons fermement à ce projet de
loi qui sert de cheval de troie à une
législation sécuritaire saupoudré ici ou
là de prétendues garanties procédurales
qui sur le fond ne change rien à son
caractère liberticide
entendre de l'otan dès le bien nous
sommes je n'ai pas répéter ce que j'ai
dit en première lecture nous sommes
comme tous nos collègues de farouche des
républicains monsieur le garde des
sceaux aussi et 2 mais aussi de
farouches adversaires du terrorisme ce
toutes ses formes nous ne nions pas et
nous ne minimisons pas le risque
terroriste et c'est d'ailleurs pourquoi
nous participons activement à la
commission denquête créée par notre
assemblée sur les réseaux djihadistes
mais nous le faisons pour comprendre
trouver des pistes pour prévenir
dissuader avant s'il le faut réprimer
mais nous refusons de céder à la
pression exercée par le gouvernement
pour mettre en scène un climat
sécuritaire aggravée pour
instrumentaliser des risques terroristes
afin de porter atteinte aux droits
fondamentaux à l'état de droit dans des
domaines qui vont au delà de la seule
lutte antiterroriste commerce merci
chers collègues la parole est au
président mézard pour le groupe rdse
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues
nous voterons très majoritairement ce
texte qui nous revient après cmp
la lutte
contre le terrorisme
a toujours été un exercice difficile
surtout dans la recherche d'un équilibre
entre la défense des libertés
individuelles
en recherchant à concilier le
pragmatisme et les principes ce qui est
toujours difficile
le texte que nous nous apprêtons à voter
n'empêchera pas totalement la diffusion
de la propagande terroriste sur internet
ni sur les réseaux sociaux qui
constituent aujourd'hui l'outil majeur
de sa propagation vous avez d'ailleurs
madame la ministre a rappelé que le plan
contre la radicalisation violente et les
filières terroristes prévoient une série
d'actions préventif qui sont absolument
indispensables
ce texte ne va pas non plus révolutionné
les moyens mis à la disposition des
services de police et de renseignement
notre groupe a eu l'occasion de le
rappeler en première lecture nous
considérons qu'il serait souhaitable que
le parlement réfléchissent à une réforme
en profondeur
des moyens d'investigation ou encore de
l'organisation des services de police et
de renseignement
d'autant que le rapport du procureur
robert qui a quand même fléché un
certain nombre de pistes intéressantes
en la matière
permis quand même un certain nombre
d'avancées comme d'ailleurs l'adoption
de l'article 10 bis qui est issu d'un de
nos amendements mais il faut reconnaître
que ce texte constitue un début de
réponse au nouveau terrorisme qui
évoluent en fonction des mutations
techniques et sociologique
terrorisme qui essaime ses idées dans
nos quartiers au sein des esprits les
plus vulnérables et les différentes
dispositions que contient ce texte
permet normalement permettre de faire
avancer positivement les choses ce sera
déjà un progrès
il y à l'interdiction de sortie du
territoire en premier lieu nous avons en
première lecture rappeler quand même les
difficultés posées au niveau de la
défense des libertés par rapport à un
acte qui est important qui est grave
c'est d'interdire un de nos concitoyens
de sortir du territoire
cette mesure permettra d' entraver le
départ d'individus radicalisés par le
retrait de la carte d'identité du
passeport mais elle et d'autres l'ont
dit ici attentatoire à la liberté
d'aller et venir elle devra être motivé
et prix sur la base de faits
circonstanciés
notre groupe a regretté d'ailleurs que
le principe général du droit de la
défense n'ait pas trouvé sa place dans
cette procédure de sanction
administrative
car une dérogation à la norme du
principe du contradictoire aurait pu
être introduite en cas d'urgence c'est
un choix qu'a fait le gouvernement dont
acte
les attentats perpétrés il y a deux
semaines au canada renforce encore la
pertinence d'une analyse qui met en
évidence l'émergence
d'un nouveau phénomène terroriste qui
touche l'ensemble des pays occidentaux
comme cela était le cas en france ses
accents été commis par deux jeunes
citoyen canadien né et grandi au canada
nouvellement radicaliser l'un des
présumés coupables considéré comme un
voyage à haut risque s'était vu retirer
son passeport donc le retrait du
passeport n'a pas été une réponse
suffisante une constatation
l'interdiction administrative du
territoire à destination de
ressortissants étrangers potentiellement
dangereux qui vont se voir interdire
l'entrée la circulation sur le
territoire français permettra dans un
premier temps de combler un manque bien
connu du système schengen mais nous
espérons madame la ministre que les
négociations autour d'une adaptation du
code des frontières schengen aboutira
rapidement ce défi majeur du contrôle
des frontières extérieures terrestres et
maritimes de l'espace schengen est
aujourd'hui devenu une question
fondamentale pour l'union européenne et
nos concitoyens concernant le blocage
des sites faisant l'apologie du djihad
un point mérite d'être souligné
outre la question de son efficacité
qui peut être contestée au regard des
renseignements comme regarder délai de
blocage et du caractère transnational de
ces problématiques les outils numériques
ne constitue que la face émergée de la
liberté rory ce qui est lui-même
conséquent et sa face immergée est celle
du financement du terrorisme lui même
des flux financiers et monétaires qui
transite le groupe terroriste djihadiste
des chais désormais l'organisation
terroriste la plus riche de la planète
avec une fortune estimée à plus de 2,3
milliards de dollars nous ne pouvons
occulter le fait que lutter contre le
terrorisme c'est aussi lutter contre son
financement par le biais du blanchiment
d'argent un rapport récent de tracfin a
mis en évidence la difficulté qu'il y a
à repérer les manoeuvres de blanchiment
s'agissant des opérations répétées
fractionné de faibles montants et
parfois de compensation informelle à
distance une note du ministère de
l'économie a souligné le fait que je les
cite bien que le secteur financier soit
régulée depuis longtemps les soumis à la
surveillance constante des autorités de
contrôle prenant la forme de contrôle
permanent sur pièces et sur place ils
devaient exposer à des risques
spécifiques en matière de blanchiment
des capitaux et de financement du
terrorisme
il faudrait s'interroger sur le rôle
joué par sare certains pays du golfe
dans le financement du terrorisme
le trésor américain a apporté la
première preuve que l'argent du qatar
avait bien permis à des individus
candidats au djihad de rejoindre la
syrie dallest en irak et où le vent a
bénéficié de la manne destinée aux
différents groupes d'insurgés syriens
luttant contre le régime de bachar
el-assad une enveloppe financée en
grande partie par des acteurs étatiques
arabie saoudite qatar relayé par de
riches donateurs de ces mêmes pays et
nous ne pouvons durablement tolérer que
des investissements massifs dans nos
pays occidentaux finances des crimes
tout aussi massif au moyen-orient
d'autres pistes de réflexions devront
être esquissée dans l'avenir si les
temps après ces propos prospectif mais
qui me paraissent indispensables
nous voterons très majoritairement ce
texte
merci cher collègue
monsieur cabanel a demandé la parole
vous avez
la parole chers collègues merci mme la
présidente mais chers collègues que
s'était excusé mois d'intérim pour le
débat mais c'était pour un rectificatif
de vote
concerné le scrutin numéro 7 à la
discussion du projet de loi relatif à la
délimitation des régions il a été
indiqué que j'ai voté pour l'adoption de
cet amendement je tenais à préciser que
je souhaitais voté contre cet amendement
versata données de votre mise au point
elle sera publiée au journal officiel
donc désormais la parole est un chant
patrick courtois pour le groupe ump
merci
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois messieurs les rapporteurs
sharks l'oeil
quelle satisfaction qu'un large
consensus permettent l'adoption d'un
texte aujourd'hui indispensables pour
compléter notre législation sur les
dispositifs de lutte contre le
terrorisme
sans revenir sur ses besoins réels je
concentrerai mon propos sur le texte que
nous avons élaboré en commission mixte
paritaire le 21 octobre dernier
notamment la disposition portant sur le
délit d' entreprise individuelle nous
avons été nombreux à dire dès le début
de la discussion
l'importance de la création du délit
d'entreprises individuelles
l'introduction de ce nouvel article code
pénal consistant à élargir la définition
de l'acte de terrorisme est nécessaire
face à l'évolution du terrorisme comme
l'a démontré notamment la ferme ra qui a
tragiquement inauguré l'ère nouvelle des
loups solitaires ces individus marginaux
est difficilement prévisible de plus la
situation internationale impose que nous
ayons des outils juridiques précis afin
d'interdire la sortie du territoire à
certains individus lorsque des raisons
sérieuses laisse penser que cette
personne souhaitent se déplacer à
l'étranger soit pour participer à des
activités terroristes soit pour un
déplacement sur un théâtre d'opérations
de groupements terroristes et dans des
conditions susceptibles de le conduire à
porter atteinte à la sécurité publique
lors de ce retour sur le territoire
français
malgré la critique de certaines
associations il est également pertinent
de prévoir l'interdiction administrative
d'entrée sur notre territoire à
l'encontre de ressortissants d'un pays
membre de l'union européenne ou tout
membre de sa famille en cas de menace
réelle pour l'intérêt fondamental de la
société cette mesure s'inscrit
d'ailleurs dans la continuité de la
résolution numéro 2178 le 24 septembre
2014 du conseil de sécurité des nations
unies sur les combattants terroristes
étrangers qui prévoient notamment de
lutter contre la mobilité internationale
des terroristes en empêchant leur accès
ou leur transit sur le territoire des
états membres de l'onu
certains ressortissants étrangers qui ne
résident pas habituellement en france
peuvent représenter une menace grave
pour la société en particulier
lorsqu'ils peuvent eux-mêmes circuler
librement au sein de l'espace schengen
tel peut être le cas de ressortissants
d'états membres de l'union liés aux
mouvances radicales voire à des
organisations terroristes qui se rendent
ponctuellement en france pour des
séjours de très courte durée
or seules les personnes résidant en
france peuvent faire l'objet d'une
mesure d'expulsion
je souhaiterais aborder l'un des autres
principaux sujets de divergence nous
avons avec nos collègues députés il
s'agit du régime des délits de
provocation au tourisme et d' apologie
du terrorisme les avions effectivement
deux approches différentes
l'assemblée nationale en accord avec le
gouvernement avait extrait l'apologie à
la provocation autorise sme de la loi
sur la presse de 1881 afin de prendre en
compte le fait que l'utilisation
d'internet fait partie intégrante de la
stratégie de plusieurs groupes
terroristes nous avions en revanche au
sénat suivi la proposition pertinente
des rapporteurs qu'il introduisait dans
le code pénal que l'apologie et la
provocation au terrorisme via internet
la décision de la commission mixte
paritaire de déplacer ces deux délits de
la loi sur la presse vers le code pénal
et d'aggraver leur sanction lorsqu'ils
sont commis sur internet je rappelle
sept ans d'emprisonnement et 100 mille
euros d'amande au lieu de cinq ans
d'emprisonnement et de 75000 euros
demande est acté mais nous aurons dans
un avenir proche à réfléchir peut-être
plus sereinement à ce que nous voulons
donner comme avenir à la loi sur la
presse qui aujourd'hui regroupe un
certain nombre de délits qui seraient
commis dans des conditions bien éloignée
de la presse au sens de la législation
du 19e siècle enfin je souhaiterais vous
faire part de quelques regrets
même si je sais que le parlement devrait
être amenés prochainement à légiférer en
manière pénitentiaire pour traiter la
question de l'encellulement individuel
je trouve regrettable que le
gouvernement n'ait pas eu une position
plus claire sur la question de
l'encellulement des personnes condamnées
pour terrorisme
alors que nous savons tous que la prison
est l'un des lieux du recrutement du
terrorisme le rapport élaboré par
l'alcool dans le cadre du budget de
l'administration pour 2015 temps a
confirmé la radicalisation et le
prosélytisme en milieu pénitentiaire
c'est pourquoi la lutte contre le
prosélytisme en prison est un chantier
urgent à ouvrir mes chers collègues par
ailleurs j'avais déposé un amendement
avec mes collègues frassa et gournac sur
le sujet de la lutte contre la fraude
aux prestations sociales
de la même manière le gouvernement est
resté timoré sur ce plan certes et je le
conçois le sujet est extrêmement
complexe et ne pouvaient être abordées
ainsi aussi rapidement sans perspective
plus large mais nous ne cachons pas
derrière cette réalité cette question
mérite une réflexion approfondie mes
chers collègues car les prestations
sociales sont certes un droit mais elle
implique aussi des déboires de celles et
ceux qui les perçoivent envers la france
mais chaque collègue les dispositions
adoptées dans cette loi vont contribuer
à améliorer et renforcer le dispositif
existant en matière de lutte contre le
terrorisme c'est donc sans aucune
surprise que le groupe ump votera ce
texte issu d'un consensus général ce
dont je me réjouis car cela n'a pas
toujours été forcément le cas lors des
précédentes législature pourtant sur le
même type de circonstances merci chers
collègues là présent la parole est
maintenant aux présidents jean pierre
sueur
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur les rapporteurs monsieur le
président de la commission des lois mes
chers collègues
le contexte international et national
justifie hélas
ce projet de loi de lutte contre le
terrorisme
je pense que cela apparaît avec une
grande évidence lorsque l'on suit
l'actualité tragique
de ces derniers mois et de ces dernières
semaines
notre commission a eu je crois une assez
bonne idée
lorsqu'elle a choisi il ya quelques mois
de confier à deux collègues le rapport
sur ce texte aussi je commencerais par
remercier alain richard et jean jacques
hyest qui ont ensemble chercher à
dégager nous aider de dégager au sénat
une position qui ne soit pas une
supposition d'un consensus
fallacieux mais une position claire
solide par rapport au projet de loi du
gouvernement
nous devons lutter contre le terrorisme
le terrorisme c'est la négation de la
liberté est d'abord de la liberté de
vivre
et nous sommes profondément attachés aux
libertés au sénat particulièrement
mais nous devons concilier ces deux
exigences
sans oublier ni l'une ni l'autre c'est
ce à quoi nous nous sommes employés lors
des travaux de la commission mixte
paritaire
plusieurs points forts
se trouve
dans ce texte
l'interdiction administrative de sortie
du territoire
bien entendu qui pourra être soumise au
contrôle de la du tribunal administratif
de la juridiction administrative et à
son jugement
je rappelle que le sénat grâce au sénat
il a été prévu que les changes
contradictoires de la personne impliquée
pour être avec les autorités pourraient
eux duré 8 jours et non 15 jours ce qui
était la position initiale du
gouvernement
le sénat a obtenu aussi que la mesure
que la promulgation de la mesure soit
motivé
et qu'il soit indiqué le recours
possible au référé liberté
avec ce qui est assez exceptionnel dans
l'espèce justifier le fait qu'il y est
un délai de 4 mois donné au tribunal
administratif pour statuer
deuxièmement la création du délit
d'entreprise individuelle de terrorisme
qui apparaît à l'évidence nécessaire
quand on regarde ce qui s'est
effectivement passé dans notre pays et
dans un pays proche
troisièmement la question eu deux du
délit d'apologie et de provocation au
terrorisme nous en avons beaucoup parlé
puisque nous avions imaginé nous
rapporteur l'avait proposé en au sénat
un dispositif qui serait différent selon
que le délit soit commis sur internet ou
sur un média classique
nos collègues amis députés nous ont
persuadé lors de la commission mixte
paritaire qu'il était difficile de
justifier le fait d'une réponse
différente en terme de poursuite
selon la nature du support du délit
c'est pourquoi un accord a été trouvé
pour que l'ensemble de la mesure figure
désormais dans le code pénal étant
entendu que le fait que le délit soit
commis sur internet pourra constituer
une circonstance aggravante
je souhaite enfin pour terminer
abordé la question du blocage des sites
internet
qui développe l'apologie du terrorisme
l'incitation au recrutement de personnes
pour des entreprises à caractère
terroriste
je signalerai d'abord que le sénat a lui
même proposé que la personnalité
qualifiée désignée par la cnil soit elle
même membre de la cnil est entendu que
les députés ont souhaité y à juste titre
que ce ne fut pas un parlementaire il ya
là quelque chose d'important il ya
beaucoup d'autorités administratives
indépendantes peut être trop il convient
de réfléchir et notre ami patrice gélard
ya contribué et j'espère qu'on reviendra
sur sa proposition de loi à une
meilleure définition d absolument mon
cher collègue des autorités
administratives indépendantes
toujours est il que l'idée même qu'une
autorité administrative indépendante
désignée elle même une autorité
qualifiée à une personne qualifiée qui
lui auraient été étrangères était
vraiment une idée que nous n'aurions pas
pu soutenir le sénat a aussi ajouté
le déférence le des
référencement des sites excusez moi et
aussi nous sommes revenus sur à
l'initiative de l'assemblée nationale
sur le fait que le blocage des sites
devaient s'opérer en 24 heures le sénat
ayant pensé dans un premier temps que 48
heures était plus réaliste pour que le
blocage chute effective alors je voulais
conclure en disant mes chers collègues
que j'ai vu sur les sites internet de
toutes natures de fleurir des quantités
d'ailleurs il ya parfois un véritable
bombardement
de deux d'expression selon lesquelles je
cite ce texte serait une atteinte sans
précédent aux libertés
mes chers collègues j'ai écouté nos
collègues la première liberté c'est
quand même la liberté de vivre et de
vivre en sécurité
et je redis quitte à recevoir de
nouvelles rafales je prends des risques
que je considère qu'on ne peut pas
considérer
je considère mais les électeurs
s'exprimeront nous sommes en demandera
si heureusement oui ils s'exprimeront
mais je considère qu'on ne peut pas
considérer dans une société démocratique
que l'espace dit internet serait un
espace
par rapport auquel on se résigne ray au
fait qu'il ne serait régie par aucune
loi dès lors qu'on serait sur internet
il n'y aurait plus de place pour les
lois relatives à la vie privée
relatives au respect du droit d'auteur
relatives à la propriété intellectuelle
relative à la répression des propos
racistes xénophobes
homophobes et antisémites islamophobes
et caetera et je hais et aussi de
l'apologie du terrorisme
je ne comprends pas pourquoi je veux
bien qu'on me dise que c'est difficile
c'est vrai qu'il faut trouver des
solutions
en jouant la carte de la coopération
européenne de la coopération
internationale qu'il faut trouver des
mesures plus efficace qu'il y a des
failles tout à fait d'accord et nous
avons beaucoup à travailler en tant que
législateur sur ce sujet mais nous ne
pouvons pas nous résigner à ce que
n'importe quoi soit fait quand je dis
n'importe quoi n'importe quoi eu égard
aux égards à l'apologie du terrorisme et
à tous les délits que j'ai cités tout à
l'heure par rapport au racisme à la
xénophobie et cetera et cetera
mais j'ai dit madame madame eliane
assassi premièrement je n'en mets
intellectuellement soyons honnête je ne
vous ai pas mis en cause d'ailleurs vous
n'avez pas dit cela je ne vous n'avez
pas dit ça j'ai mis en cause un certain
nombre de parole et des cris qui sont
multipliées sur internet selon
lesquelles nous serions en votes en
votant cette loi nous agirions à
l'opposé des libertés nous serions
attentatoires aux libertés jld et la
liberté de dire ici que je ne partage en
rien ses propos et que je considère
qu'il est de la responsabilité du
législateur de légiférer de manière à ce
que les règles de droit qui sont
protectrice des libertés s'applique
aussi sur internet je vous remercie et
chers collègues
la parole est à jean yves le conte pour
le groupe socialiste
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre madame le ministre excusez moi
mes chers collègues
dans la ligne de jean pierre sueur vous
savez combien j'ai exprimé lors du débat
en première lecture un certain nombre de
questionnements sur un certain nombre
d'articles de ce texte
mais arrivé ici à la fin de la
commission mixte paritaire même si bien
entendu le texte qui arrive est un texte
d'équilibré qui ne représente pas
l'equilibre que serait souhaitée si je
l'avais et qui moi même je dois saluer
le travail des rapporteurs qui ont porté
au sénat et dans les échanges avec
l'assemblée nationale l'ensemble des
préoccupations qui ont été indiquées
lors du débat en première lecture et qui
permettent aujourd'hui même si le texte
n'est probablement pas parfait de dire
que le débat a été utile et et a permis
d'améliorer un texte qui était
nécessaire
j'émettrais toutefois
sur l'article 1 bis qui a été évoqué par
madame benbassa et madame à ça si
effectivement quelques regrets dans la
mesure où le nouveau la nouvelle
rédaction de du code d'entrée et de
séjour des étrangers en france
va très au delà d'un parallélisme entre
l'interdiction de sortie du territoire
anat élections de rentrer dans
territoire puisque ça ne va pas juste
pour la lutte contre le terrorisme ce
qui finalement aurait été logique mais
on va beaucoup plus loin puisqu'on
évoque les menaces pour les intérêts
fondamentales de la société l'ordre
public et pour les relations
internationales de la france lorsque des
personnes susceptibles d'être interdits
d'entrée sur le territoire sont non
membres d'un pays de l'union européenne
ressortissant d'un pays membre de
l'union européenne il me semble que cet
élargissement
effectivement
peut poser un peu de difficulté et je
serai demandeurs de quelques précisions
de la part du gouvernement sur ce sujet
parce qu'il me semble que il est
absolument indispensable d'abord de
préserver le principe de la liberté de
circulation dans l'espace de liberté de
circulation qu'est l'espace schengen et
d'autre part de veiller à ce que en
particulier lorsqu'on dit le menace pour
les relations internationales de la
france que ça ne porte en aucun cas
atteinte à la possibilité pour la france
de respecter la convention de genève
relative relative à la mise en oeuvre du
droit d'asile parce que si effectivement
dans la loi il y à une disposition qui
permet de remettre en cause la présence
sur le territoire d'une personne pour
raison de relations internationales
alors un état étranger serait tout à
fait légitimement nos solutions de
demander à ce que le gouvernement
français pour préserver ses bonnes
relations avec
son pays ne reçoivent pas telle ou telle
personne donc là moi je
m'insurge est plutôt je m'inquiète sur
la conjugaison de cet article un avis
avec eux le rôle que nous devons avoir
en terme de préservation du droit
d'asile une fois que j'ai indiqué cela
je voulais aussi dire que j'ai été
choquée lors du débat sur un certain
nombre de prises de positions plutôt de
nos collègues à l'assemblée nationale
philippe goujon monsieur meyer habib
monsieur claude goasguen madame marion
maréchal-le pen qui proposait pour les
personnes qui seraient susceptibles d'
interdiction de sortie du territoire
mesures administratives une déchéance de
nationalité
ce qui me semble c'est j'allais dire une
double erreur d'abord une erreur sur le
sens même de cette mesure qui est une
interdiction administrative préventive
ce n'est en aucun cas
une peine ou les conséquences d'une
instruction et une décision judiciaire
pour ça il ya l'article 5 et donc il n'y
a pas de raison de considérer que parce
que de manière préventive quelqu'un sera
interdit de sortie du territoire
il devrait être déchu de la nationalité
française
il ya une vraie confusion sur le sens de
l'article 20 qui est préventif et de
l'article 5 qui est punitif dans cette
fois ci on ne comprend pas ça c'est
dommage on introduit
c'est ainsi qu'on on fait croire que
cette loi est attentatoire aux libertés
en particulier en ce qui concerne
l'article 1
deuxièmement sur le sens même de la
déchéance de nationalité
la nationalité c'est binaire on l'a où
on ne l'a pas on ne peut pas inventer
des deux nationalités qu'on aurait dit
qu'on serait susceptible de perdre parce
qu'à ce moment là quel est le sens de
l'intégration s'il ya des français puis
à des demies français une fois qu'on est
français quand on est français on est
français on n'a aucune susceptibilité
n'a aucune on ne peut pas être traité
différemment dans la loi que les autres
sinon comment peut-on parler
d'intégration et de ce point de vue
quand même il y a les dispositions déjà
dans la loi et c'est pour ça que je dis
qu'elle ne
confusion entre l'article 1 et l'article
5 parce que il y a quand même dans dans
le code de la nationalité aujourd'hui au
cas où une personne aurait acquis la
nationalité puis on s'apercevrait que
finalement c'était une erreur
il ya déjà des dispositions pour la
déchéance si la personne n'est condamné
en particulier pour
actes terroristes
c'est dans la loi déjà et c'est pour ça
que je dis que ceux qui regrettaient que
dans le ça ne soit pas c'est parce
qu'ils auront de la tête pour l'article
1 et donc il y avait confusion parce que
si on s'est trompé qu'on a d'elle donné
aujourd'hui la nationalité à quelqu'un
qui effectivement a conduit un acte de
terrorisme alors qu'il a acquis la
nationalité française la loi prévoit
déjà la déchéance enfin en conclusion je
dirais que bon ben c'est un texte
d'équilibré qui ont répond aux exigences
et aux
défis du moment devrait peut-être voulu
qu'il soit un peu différent sur certains
points mais ils étaient dans tous les
cas indispensable maintenant il ya des
pistes qui ont été tracées en
particulier la piste de la coopération
européenne qui est indispensable
la coopération internationale car ne
croyons pas que c'est un problème franco
français c'est un problème même pas
européen mais le maroc ou l'egypte ont
aussi ses difficultés c'est un problème
que énormément de et on ne peut
l'aborder de cette manière là alors
voilà à la fin de cette discussion
j'émettrais un vote positif avec
quelques bémols mais tout en ayant bien
conscience que c'est un démarche d'
équilibre et la conclusion de cette
démarche là
merci chers collègues la discussion
générale est close
je rappelle qu'en application de
l'article 42 alinéa 12 du règlement le
sénat examine ans après l'assemblée
nationale le texte élaboré par la
commission mixte paritaire
il se prononce par un seul vote sur
l'ensemble du texte en ne retenant que
les amendements présentés ou acceptés
par le gouvernement
nous passons donc à la présentation de
l'amendement du gouvernement
savait la parole madame la ministre la
présidente mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs il s'agit le gouvernement vous
propose un amendement de coordination 12
effet et à messieurs les rapporteurs
tout à l'heure je vous laisse en prendre
connaissance il s'agit juste de
remplacer à l'article 9 au deuxième
alinéa après le mot apologie d'insérer
les mots 8e et 9e qui sont remplacés par
les mots 7e et 8e à vis de la commission
alors conformément à l'article 42 alinéa
12 du règlement jeu mettre aux voix
l'ensemble du projet de loi dans la
rédaction résultant du texte élaboré par
la commission mixte paritaire
modifié par l'amendement du gouvernement
y at il des demandes d'explications de
vote monsieur ravier
même
oui madame la présidente madame la
ministre
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs s'il
n'est jamais trop tard pour bien faire
il n'est jamais trop tôt non plus qui
plus est lorsqu'il s'agit de la sécurité
de nos compatriotes et for men de la
sécurité nationale cependant les mesures
ici proposés sont non seulement bien
tardive mais surtout hélas bien en-deça
des dangers réels et terriblement
actuels auxquels notre pays est
confronté
vous traitez le sujet a minima sans
jamais vous attaquer aux causes réelles
et profondes du phénomène la perte de
contrôle sur la nationalité française
d'une part et sur nos frontières d'autre
part avec l'anarchie migratoire
découlant d'un regroupement familial
permanent et du sans frontiérisme de
l'union européenne incarnée par l'espace
schengen
tout d'abord vous instaurez une
interdiction administrative de sortie du
territoire national en somme vous voulez
empêcher les apprentis terroristes les
apprentis djihadistes de partir mais
c'est plutôt de revenir qu'il faudrait
les empêcher ces mêmes agir en pompier
pyromane que de vouloir les maintenir de
force en france pour qu'ils y diffusent
leurs messages et leurs actions de haine
voulez-vous donc qu'il multiplie les
adeptes ici même comme c'est déjà le cas
dans nos prisons vous me direz alors que
l'on ne peut empêcher nos concitoyens
devenu terroriste de revenir en france
puisque c'est leur pays mais c'est là
une des clés du problème que vous vous
refuser d'aborder peut-on encore parler
comme vous le faite de compatriotes à
propos de djihadistes et de terroristes
qui convoque qui combattent aujourd'hui
pour le seul état pour le seul état
qu'ils considèrent comme légitime au
monde l'état dit islamique
et qui exclut toute appartenance
nationale et a fortiori hostiles à la
france
notre code civil en son article 25
prévoient déjà qu'un individu puisse
être déchu de la nationalité française
notamment s'il est condamné par un acte
qualifié de crime ou délit constituant
une atteinte aux intérêts fondamentaux
un taux de la nation ou bien s'il s'est
livré au profit d'un état étranger à des
actes incompatibles avec la qualité de
français et préjudiciable aux intérêts
de la france
seulement ces dispositions sont réservés
aux personnes naturalisées depuis moins
de dix ans elles sont donc parfaitement
obsolète car nous le savons bien et cela
a été répété ici ce ne sont pas
spécifiquement des naturalisés de
fraîche date qui rejette nos valeurs
pour devenir des terroristes mais des
personnes françaises depuis parfois
plusieurs générations pour le coup il y
à une discrimination entre les
naturalisés et des noms naturalisés et
vous manqué l'occasion d'y mettre fin au
reste la forme mouvante de l'état
islamique rend même ici obsolète le
terme état étranger qu'il faudrait
remplacer par celui d'intérêts étrangers
pourquoi ne pas étendre le champ du code
civil et retirer leur nationalité
française à tout les djihadistes en
particulier ainsi qu'à ceux qui incitent
au terrorisme ou en font l'apologie en
général voilà qui protégerait vraiment
nos compatriotes et les étrangers qui
veulent vivre sur notre sol en toute
sécurité et en toute liberté
ici encore vous trembler à l'idée de
créer des apatrides mais qui crée des
apatrides et si ce n'est ceux ci sony
sait si ce n'est ceux qui se profile
apatride ne seront que les cendres pour
pays que cet état dit islamique et qui a
vocation à conquérir par la terreur et
par les massacres de masse chère madame
ce sont eux mêmes qui ont choisi de
devenir des apatrides du jihad et du
terrorisme or est notre devoir nous
permet de le faire lorsque la france a
ratifié la convention sur la réduction
des cas d'apatridie en 1962 elle a émis
des réserves qui lui permettent de
traiter de tels cas au plan au lieu de
cela vous faites semblant de traiter le
sujet de la nationalité en prévoyant
simplement de retirer la pièce
d'identité c'est un trompe l'oeil qui
n'empêchera rien
ou si peu dans un espace schengen où
vous où vous avez choisi d'abolir tout
contrôle des frontières derniers grands
points non traitées dans ce texte et non
les moindres le laxisme migratoires et
ses conséquences il n'ya pas qu'internet
il n'y a pas qu'un internet qui soit
vecteur d'endoctrinement lice
l'islamisme radical à ses relais partout
dans notre pays dans les centaines de
quartiers et pas seulement dans les
quartiers nord de marseille il y à une
pression un endoctrinement de rue au
coeur des cités qui est exercée par des
fanatiques et autres imams autoproclamés
radicaux dans bien des quartiers les
signes extérieurs de l'islamisme radical
gagner du terrain
les codes vestimentaires des femmes
comme celui des hommes lattes est sans
ambiguïté alors que la porosité est
évidente entre les migrations
incontrôlées
et ses sphères de régularité vous
continuez à l' vous continuez à l'idée
de laisser circuler des éléments
extrémistes dans nos quartiers qui plus
est en provenance de pays où il n'ya pas
de liberté religieuse dans ce contexte
votre loi souligne surtout votre
impuissance nez de votre attachement
inconditionnel aux règles
internationales les plus néfastes nous
devons lutter contre les dogues
fanatique mais ne soyons pas le soyons
plus des fanatiques d'autres dogme qui
empêche de protéger vraiment totalement
nos compatriotes c'est pourquoi je
m'abstiendrai avec mon collègue monsieur
rachline sur ce texte je vous remercie
autre explication de vote madame boulet
vous avez la parole
voilà voilà voilà c'est pas cette bombe
à l'aveu le
président à la parole le président même
le ministre mes chers collègues oui
juste quelques mots sur ce texte aussi
si ce pays est si ce parlement est
devenu liberticide et autoritaire je
pense qu'à une grande épidémie
d'autoritarisme
en europe et dans le monde parce que
même les anglais champions de l'habeas
corpus prennent aussi ce type de mesures
qui sont prises dans toute l'europe dans
la mesure où elles répondent à un vrai
besoin tout le monde l'a dit
ce texte est un texte qui a trouvé un
équilibre certes dans l'urgence est
certes avec des imperfections je demeure
absolument persuadé que l'article 9 bien
qu'il soit nécessaire de supprimer des
contenus parce qu'il ya des contenus qui
sont absolument insupportables dont on
comprend bien qu'internet est le vecteur
de conversion le vecteur de promotion
est aussi le vecteur agences de tourisme
vers les pays du jihad je suis
absolument convaincu que le blocage tel
qu'il est prévu dans le texte ne sera
pas efficace et qu'il faudra trouver
d'autres moyens je continue à penser que
la suppression du contenu ne passera pas
par le blocage du site
le texte qu'on a voté donc que nous
apprêtons à voter dans dans l'urgence
certains n'ont signalé à la tribune
évidemment et elliptique de deux sujets
majeurs
m23 la prévention les circuits
financiers et le milieu carcéral vous
savez que notre haute assemblée vient de
réunir une commission denquête et j'ai
beaucoup d'espoir dans cette commission
denquête et surtout dans l' usage qui
est fait ces conclusions car le
gouvernement a parfaitement pris note du
rapport de nos collègues de l'assemblée
nationale e christophe cavard et jean
jacques urvoas
pour modifier notamment et réformer
les services de sécurité du territoire
j'espère donc que nous pouvons revenir
sur ce sujet à la suite des travaux de
la commission denquête que je préside et
dont jean pierre sueur et le rapporteur
et que nous pourrons discuter de ces
conclusions et proposer des dispositions
complémentaires qu'ils sont qui sont
absolument nécessaires car le tout
répressif ne peut pas fonctionner dans
cette matière si nous ne l'environnement
ont pas de mesures préventives si nous
ne faisons pas qu'à des flux financiers
et souhaits si nous n'essayons pas
d'endiguer la radicalisation non
seulement dans certains quartiers mais
aussi dans nos prisons je vous remercie
merci madame ou les pas d'autres
explications de vote
je mets donc aux voix l'ensemble du
projet de loi renforçant les
dispositions relatives à la lutte contre
le terrorisme dans la rédaction
résultant du texte proposé par la
commission mixte paritaire
modifié par
l'amendement du gouvernement qui est
pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient
le projet de loi est définitivement
adopté
voilà vous êtes donc pu suivre l'examen
du projet de loi de lutte contre le
terrorisme dans un instant vous
retrouver michel grossiord et perrine
tarneaud pour preuve par trois ils
reçoivent aujourd'hui le président du
sénat gérard larcher
oh